what a Prime Minister maybe summer
tearing away from Downing Street but
something else is missing as well
the letter O from the famous street sign
in fact the letters A and B have
disappeared from Street shop and
Hospital size across the country as part
of a campaign to encourage people to
give blood or with us now is John Latham
assistant director for data services at
NHS Blood and transplant and so explain
to us the idea behind this because this
is really capture people's imagination
in fact it was trending on Twitter over
the weekend
how we doing Sarah [ __ ] as a yes it's a
very simple idea I mean the idea behind
as we needed to create new donors what
more donors come forward we when I'm
Friday with a big campaign explaining we
seen a 40% drop off since 2005 loads of
factors behind that and what we want to
do is only simple way of getting
people's imagination and how can I help
how could they come forward and even if
you can't donate Wales could you do to
help us so we've been taking the O's the
A's the B's out of people's addresses
out of people's names celebrities have
come on board big completo come on board
as he saved me down street dentistry to
come on board by taking those letters
out and saying these are the types of
blood groups of the missing please come
forward and donate blood we get our
message out to a lot of people very
quickly just in terms of donors do you
find that numbers are dropping at the
moment is there a steady rise where are
you on on nation total new donors it's a
world working on on actually the the
borough has been a drop off in the last
ten years and for us in the North Wales
it's 40% in other parts of the country a
world it can be even more and you know
we've done some research with virtually
the International Blood Services to try
and find out the reasons behind that
I'll miss all four main factors have
come out firstly people have less time
it's just you're working much harder
than you were ten years ago and
obviously displaying sort of that blood
donation you do in your spare time if
you have less bed time you're not going
to be able to donate tattoos seems a
very simple thing Barry time David
Beckham comes out and has a new tattoo
and it goes worldwide that impacts us
because we have to defer you if you've
had a tattoo for four months and from
personal experience I find it quite hard
to give blood I've got a rare blood type
and I'm always getting letters through
the PO saying
in your area yeah Booker slots come and
give blood every time I do it seems that
there's a clamor for people to give
blood and I can't get an appointment and
I can't jump to the front of the queue
because I've got a rare blood group and
I'm always getting these letters so is
there not some some kind of system where
not just me but people who are
constantly asked to give blood because
they have a rare blood group to get
priority it can be very frustrating when
we have just introduced an online
booking system that gives you access to
all of the appointments around the
country so you you're moving around you
can see booking in other parts of the
country if you wanted to if you call us
call center then they do have some apply
message they there have in the back
pocket particularly for the the groups
that we really need more of so the
o-negative groups the rarer blood group
so you're talking about there and even
from new donors now we don't have huge
numbers of us because we want to give
everybody access to to come in and to
donate but we do know there are some
blood groups which are particularly
important to us and how severe is the
shortage now well isn't a shortage we're
actually planning for the future I mean
this is a new donors actually tech
probably a year and a half before they
become active donors we need to bring
them in they have to try us out see with
that comfortable giving blood come a
second or third time and once they're
comfortable with that then they're more
likely become the loyal donor who come
in regularly put it always put into the
calendar and what we're trying to do is
prepare for a year a half two years down
the line so we want to make sure we've
got you know new generation of blood
donors coming forward now so they'll be
able to replace some of the older
dancers but it's not it's not a question
that now you know people have a severe
action they need blood they won't be
able to get it if they go to have
something on the stock so the moments
are very very good if you have a severe
accident what tends to happen is you we
may have o-negative blood put in you
depending on where you are and that
stabilizes you before the clinic right
blood type and that's that's one of the
areas where we always do have a slight
challenges around Oh negative blood I
mean that's obviously the important
thing bet I mean how did you set about
persuading you know Downing Street and
West mr. castle that you wanted to
vandalize there so I don't think it's
more about simplicity of the message
it's not a big ask
celebrities been doing it I see - it's
some big organizations in waters losing
their ray I mean you know you normally
think it's people on stag nights who's
still in bed with the RO and they're a
but
big organizations I understand
appreciate the need for creating
awareness campaigns you sometimes can't
ask for money which is we are public
service we don't ask for money we just
asked a little bit of a exposure to
their brands and that allows us to get
our message out very clearly and you
know it's more and more organizations
are coming on now so we're in National
Blood week we started this really on
Friday with the message about the 40%
and then started the work with the
organization's really today and you'll
be amazed the amount of organizations
now they've seen the the success the
campaign you are coming on who you know
pretty soon we haven't been able to get
to the same please we'll take our
letters that will go on social media
will will help you in the campaign it's
such an easy what's your favorite one
watch one your proudest or perhaps
perhaps what working with on I think
it's making the letter off yeah I think
it is the Downing Street to Berlin and
we also talk I know it's not the zero
it's the zero of 10 down streets became
one Downing Street just just for the co2
opportunity so I think those are really
and are the big ones but any
organization will help us we'd be very
grateful and we're just reassure viewers
is not vandalism you are going to give
these letters back so we say up the
secret's safe for me I'm not going to
tell you